[music]
>> The same thing said the map in Ash'arite
mind may be different in Faris mind is
different my mind is different.
He can think of writing on the board one
will say writing on the street. One will
say writing on the table.
He had habit in school to write on the
table so he think of the table. Someone
had a habit of writing on the wall so he
think of writing on the wall. So they
create that and then they give a number
1 2 3. Then you ask him number two.
Okay, what is number two? It is run.
Number three?
It is read. Number four?
It is write. Number one? It is map. You
create and then anything and then they
ask people to say 20 things.
I'm not expert in this technique because
I've got a better technique. I'll come
to it later on.
These are techniques which are helpful.
Very good. But have limitations.
I'm not expert on this technique.
This triangle
There are different ways.
Done by experts and if you do this
training course
you reach to a good level of
memorizing.
Amongst my students there were people
who were BBA, Bachelor of Business
Administration, MBA masters
and
they were part of the course.
And you found that
initially they used to top.
The best
in references
Brother Nisar
Second day, best. Third day, someone
else comes.
And then it becomes he's on the bottom
because he's using technique of mapping
or triangle or whatever it is.
The best technique is
all these techniques of mapping have
limitations. We had expert come in our
school who could
25 words, 30 words.
Okay, I said okay, fine.
Surah Nisa?
Okay. Then Surah Nisa? Three, four,
fifth he could not map because he
doesn't know what Nisa is.
He was Muslim.
So for mapping you require certain
thinking.
You cannot map something which you don't
know of.
Surah Imran?
So but you told me say anything. You
didn't tell me say only in English.
You didn't tell me say only in Hindi.
So all these have limitations up to a
certain level.
And all these have benefits not that it
doesn't have. But it has limitations.
You use this technique it will help you
in certain ways.
But specially with the references of the
scriptures
it will not take you very far.
I personally don't know of anyone who
uses these techniques for giving
references in speeches. I don't know.
Or speeches in religious comparative
religion. I don't know. Maybe there are.
It will help you to a certain extent but
not the way if you see
quoting if I seen my lectures whether if
they will show the intent Quran modern
science Quran speaks about
ideology and that that that that that
that that coming
until the audience claps.
Or until they appreciate until it's
Allahu Akbar. Keep on.
There are limitations. So this when you
use the other techniques what are
available in references so person who
has done mapping also appreciates you
why? He knows like if you know
what happened when Musa Alayhis Salaam
was sent by Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala to
the people of Firaun.
They were very good in magic.
So they threw their staff it became
snake but when Musa Alayhis Salaam threw
the staff
all the snakes that were created by
fiction were gobbled up and they
realized this is not fiction and they
bowed down to Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
and they said
this is a man of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala.
They went against Firaun. Firaun said I
will chop your head off.
They said no matter. We know this is
haq.
That is Allah's magic.
It's not magic. It's a wrong word to say
for Allah.
It's not the appropriate word.
It is Allah Kun Fayakun.
How much easy be and it is.
For others we have to do illusion. We
have to do hallucination.
So therefore I believe more in the help
of Allah.
I never used anytime these techniques.
People think that there is a chip
in the brain. There's no chip. Only
Allah's help. Power point? Power from
Allah.
Inna Allaha ala kulli shai'in qadeer.
Allah has power over all things. But
this comes number one 3160.
If Allah helps you none can overcome
you. Number two?
If you strive in the way of Allah if you
do jihad if you struggle Allah will open
up your pathways. So there is striving
and struggling.
You cannot achieve this without Allah's
help. To achieve Allah's help?
The master key for Allah's help?
It's 2969. Surah Ankabut chapter 29
verse 69.
If you strive in the way of Allah Allah
will open up your pathways.
If you strive and your pathway is not
open and your striving is not correct.
I have not
come across
any student
in any of my training programs who could
not do this.
Yes. The levels differ.
But even the lowest student when he goes
out
people think he's a computer.
And
previously when we did the training
program we used to have timing. You know
timing?
Who does the fastest? At that time
I was there in the competition. Now I've
become old.
And there was a competition. What is the
time? What is the time? And then after
I've never timed myself and neither do I
intend
timing. But we found that the students
excelled.
Better. Faster.
And there were records set. How many
minutes forward backward in between
this.
You know I don't like competition.
So I'm out of the competition now.
Alhamdulillah.
Allah's help.
But hard work is important. If you don't
do hard work
if any of you cannot do it
you only have to blame yourself and no
one else.
If you cannot do it at the end of this
training program not end
within the next before half
if by the 11th 12th day you cannot do it
you have to blame no one but yourself by
the 12th or 13th day of the training
program.
Yes. The levels will differ. Those who
have done more hard work will excel
better.
But if you do hard work in the right way
you have to do it.
When you go to your country you will be
king.
They don't know that you are the 10th or
the 20th in the list. The 20th also
alhamdulillah.
But
when you go back and you relax and you
stop the hard work it will go away from
your memory.
One is hard work. One is muraja'ah.
Revision. I told you being hafiz of
Quran is one thing. Doing muraja'ah is
another thing. No, when you do muraja'ah
to such a level that you have done so
many times then muraja'ah is not
required yet.
Even when you meet
the two most famous a'immah
imams of the Haram
Sheikh Abdur Rahman Sudais
and Sheikh Saud Al-Shuraim
they have done that so many times and
you hardly find them making mistakes yet
Tarawih they say
they know very well yet
they want some peace before going
interaction
with Sheikh
the Sheikh of Madinah
Salah Al-Budair
Sheikh Abdul Muhsin Al-Qasim
Many of them tried to say okay before
Tarawih they want some time. They know
the Quran very well.
Now once you keep on revising it becomes
part of your memory. There's something
like temporary memory something like
permanent memory. Now when you do hard
work these verses will go into your
temporary memory.
Temporary memory you can quote but you
go home and then busy with other things
and you don't revise it will go away.
If you want to put it in your permanent
memory
you have to practice
>> [snorts]
>> very often. When it goes to such a level
if you don't practice also it will be
with you then
you can say that you have mastered the
art with Allah's help.
But that level comes later on.
So in this way inshallah by the time you
face 13 14
you will do hard work inshallah. If you
don't I will do hard work to make you do
hard work.
But the main test is when you get it you
have to retain it.
If you get it and you don't retain it
who's to blame? You are to blame. So now
I don't know whether all the people who
did my training yet can quote.
There are our students who are hafiz of
Quran.
They passed the school.
All cannot repeat the Quran. So, we have
muraja. How many times they have done?
We have competition.
Okay, start from Fajr.
IN ONE SHOT, complete the Quran.
How many hours? Okay, fine, 6 hours.
Okay, 7 hours. Only lunch break, salah
break.
How many mistakes? Four mistakes. Very
good. How many mistakes? Three mistakes.
Alhamdulillah. How many mistakes? No
mistakes. Summa Alhamdulillah.
So, there are huffaz. We have more than
100 huffaz in our school.
Fine. Some may have forgotten part of
it, some more.
Inshallah, one day you'll have with one
of our best huffaz that we have.
Brother Abdul Hafiz Mulla.
And you can check.
There's no planning. You check. Ask
anything and he will tell you,
inshallah.
Now, what happens? Some people, they did
muraja of the first 15 juz very well.
With the first 15, they're master. Next
15, okay, may make mistakes.
Because they have done more muraja of
the first 15 juz. The first 15, he's
very good. Not a single mistake.
The next five, four five mistakes.
Next five, 20 mistakes. Last five also
very well, okay, no mistakes.
>> [music]
[singing]
[music]